everything about immigration is about
power politics has nothing to do with
the individuals they don't uh there's
there's no sort of compassion if you
talk to these people do you care about
the little kids coming across what might
happen to teenage girls coming across
they don't care about that all they care
about is votes their whole goal is to
take Texas they've been trying to take
Texas for 20 years the only way they
take Texas is let's legalize a couple of
million people here illegally and let
them
vote
all right Senator we're going to Dive
Right In uh it is a big day in DC a lot
of Border nonsense bipartisan i' I've
started to think that bipartisan just
means we're all getting screwed is that
kind of that's typ that's typically what
happens around here but it's great to be
in your new studio you guys have gone up
to down on us you know look at this
we're doing all right somebody's got to
save free speech in this town you're
you're doing your part on the Senate
side and we're doing our part on the
tech side typically in Washington if
it's called bipartisan or if you look at
the name and it says patriotic It's
usually the opposite so it's not going
to be any good and it's been concocted
in secret this one was even worse than
than than typical it wasn't a bipartisan
gang which doesn't sound very good but
this time it was a gang of one McConnell
signed one Republican go negotiate with
the Democrats and he got his clock
cleaned on the negotiations and came out
with a bill I love Chris Murphy's
response Chris Murphy's explaining how
great this bill and he says the Border
never closes he's like really this is
this is what you're bragging about this
great border Bill the Border never
closes and that's the extraordinary
thing it was going to let 5,000 people a
day come in and then we're going to take
Extraordinary Measures on the illegal
Crossings but we were going to let them
all come through the ports no matter
what number comes through the ports
would never close all right there's
there's so much here it's so crazy so
basically on so five you're signing a
bill and well I know you're not signing
it but they wanted to push through a
bill that was going to basically allow
for 5,000 illegals a day before a
trigger anything we know the bord in
essence been open already and they
combine it with a zillion other things
that have nothing to do with in some
ways this may be worse than the existing
law under the existing law it says that
the president may allow migrants Asylum
he doesn't have to in fact we believe
the president has the power not to allow
May mean you might doesn't mean you have
to it doesn't say shall but now that
they're defining the first 4,000 as in
this category of May or shall and then
he shall do something after a certain
number it sounds as if they're codifying
that the first four or 5,000 are hey
free you don't have to do anything about
it whereas now we think the law reads
that the president May at the first
person that comes in may stop migrant
Asylum just because hey we're full we
got too many and we're just not taken
anymore right now we think that's what
the law says so this law would actually
take a step towards normalizing the
first four to 5,000 but even the rules
after the first 4 or 5,000 day which is
1.8 million a year after 1.8 million a
year the rules aren't very uh strong
they give the discretion to my orcas who
uh oh that's right they're impeaching my
orcas they're giving the discretion to
my orcas meanwhile the Biden campaign is
cutting the razor wire and removing the
cargo containers that are essentially a
wall on the border so like oh we're
going to trust them we're going to
negotiate with them and trust them to
use new power when they're right now
using their power to disrupt the border
wall so when you saw what Texas did and
what Greg Abbott did and obviously the
Supreme Court decision 54 they can't do
anything but Texas goes ahead and does
it 25 I think 25 Republican Governors
have signed on to this the santis is
sending a National Guard states rights
guy like this is kind of what you want
to happen I suppose right yeah they
really should work in concert the
federal government should be backing
them up but the states do have a role in
this and many people have said all along
yeah the states of course have a role in
in having a border see I think the way
this would work and the way this with a
strong leader would end in a couple of
weeks is everybody would be sent back
you come across the river you're just
they put you in a little boat and take
you right back across doesn't have to be
a trial you don't deserve to be in the
United States for 10 years with a ticket
for a court date 10 years their solution
is more judges yeah yeah more judges
more camps and actually more money for
Sanctuary cities everything for
Democrats every compromise with
Democrats and Falls more money but I
think people shouldn't lose sight of the
main part of this bill which is $60
billion to Ukraine who just got caught
yesterday stealing another $40 million
worth of our weapons and reselling them
to God knows too so I'm against the
Ukraine Aid because I think borrowing
the money spending over this bill would
be $15 billion total 60 billion to to
Ukraine that makes us weaker it weakens
our national security to go further in
debt when you see them put these bills
together and I've asked you this before
but since you're one of the few guys
works in the government who actually
understands how the government was set
up to work in the first place when you
see them combine these things okay we're
combining 60 billion of Ukraine Aid with
the border and some other things uh do
you you try to ever tell people hey
maybe we could separate these things
vote on one thing at a time yeah and
it's it's it's also true on things with
immigration I'm actually not against
immigration I'm actually for more lawful
immigration but we need to be these
little narrow bills instead they say
well yeah we'll increase employment
based or work-based visas but only if
you give the 18 million people already
here the right to vote and I was like
look I'm I'm pretty open on this issue I
would give work permits even to those
who came here illegally I'd probably
give some work permits but I'm not
giving them the right to vote and we're
not going to make that trade so we've
stayed at a standstill for the 12 years
I've been here no immigration changes
have happened even though I think some
incremental things could be improved
none of it happens because the Democrats
say All or Nothing comprehensive or
nothing and comprehensive for them means
all 18 million people here illegally get
to vote and I'm not for that what do you
think the Democrats intentions are here
like what do you think Biden or
whoever's driving Biden at this point
what do you think the intentions are
from all the videos we see at the border
and the amount of people flooding
everything about immigration is about
power politics has nothing to do with
the individuals they don't uh there's
there's no sort of compassion if you
talk to these people do you care about
the little kids coming across what might
happen to teenage girls coming across
they don't care about that all they care
about is votes their whole goal is to
take Texas they've been trying to take
Texas for 20 years the only way they
take Texas is let's legalize a couple of
million people here illegally and let
them vote the sooner the better that's
why they can't wait till their kids grow
up to vote cuz their kids actually might
like America and start liking American
ways become successful enter the middle
class become rich and all of a sudden
say wow America's great I don't want to
have Mexico over here I want to have a I
want to be part of this American Dream
but if you let people vote immediately
particularly if Millions come across
they come across with their own agenda
and you got to wonder I mean you see
these people flying into Mexico City
from China well dress designer clothes
thousand cell phone snapping selfies of
themsel as they come across the very few
women very few children yeah who and the
thing is is they'll eventually once they
can get normalized they'll bring in the
rest of their family um or are they here
for nefarious purposes I just want to
jump back to to your philosophy on
immigration because Libertarians tend to
be a little bit more Pro legal
immigration or having more workers here
there seems to be a little divide on the
right right now between kind of the big
Tech guys guys like Elon Musk David
Sachs who are kind of more into okay we
should bring some of these people
illegally and now there's the sort of
like I guess the Maga side of it which
is just shut down the border and figure
it out there there's people lose sight
of the fact that about a million come a
year that's what comes in about a
million legally and lawfully and uh if
you stop that if you're a restrictionist
and you say we want a half a million
next year guess what no houses are going
to be built they do a lot of work in our
country a lot of Migrant workers and I'm
also of the opinion of this and this is
where I think attitude makes a
difference to the Republican part is
ever going to grow I think some of the
best Americans just got
here I I know many first generation
Americans I live in a town a small town
in Kentucky we have people from Bosnia
we have people from Burma we have and
there's a question of how many is too
many but at the same time they're good
people they own restaurants uh one of
the most successful people in our town
now is bosni and has a trucking company
uh so they're they're good people
working hard and we need to value that
if we as Republicans sort of have this
oh everybody's bad all you know
everybody from foreign lands is evil
which I think is some some ways uh the
way Republicans are depicting themselves
I think there is a danger to that and of
the million I think we could probably
bring in 1.5 million but I don't want
another half a million people flooding
across the border and I would make it
work-based so I have a bill to double
the amount of employment based visas
these are employment uh EB 1 through
five and uh five I'm a big fan of it's
you got a million dollars you want to
come to the US we take your million
bucks and you start a business and hire
people and you can come in who wouldn't
want rich people to come to our country
so what would what do you want basically
to happen from now to save the election
when potentially we could have an
Administration flip and things are a
little more iMed the bottom line is this
needs to be a debate about enforcing the
current law not changing the law the
changes I think uh codify and sort of
say to everybody it's okay to bring in
1.8 million year that Bill's dead and I
hope it goes nowhere yeah now um until
then we'll debate why doesn't the
president use the current law on the
border but there's another debate that
shouldn't be lost in this and won't go
away and that's why should we send $60
billion to Ukraine um and now we've got
the speaker and I had high hopes for the
speaker what's the argument for it when
you talk to your colleagues that are for
it at this point because you've been
you've been against it the entire time I
had you on when you were just saying can
we just get some receipts how about you
guys just let us know what we're paying
for and you couldn't even get that well
at least let us know what they're
stealing you know I mean if you're going
to steal a certain per at least let us
investigate what's being stolen um no
the thing is is it's a judgment call
which do you think is more in our
national interest or more in our
national security benefit is it fighting
a war and continuing that war to be or
allowing it to come to a negotiated
settlement I think coming to a
negotiated settlement is better for our
national security but I also think the
number one threat to our national
security is our debt we're accumulating
debt in about three months ago we were
accumulating about a trillion dollars
every three months over 300 billion
dollars there are people saying that
it's so out of control that the debt
problem really is our number one
national security threat so I'm not for
borrowing more money but I'm really
disappointed in the speaker the speaker
starts out his speakership what's the
first bill he pass 14 billion for Israel
paid for I said okay I can support that
I actually supported it in the Senate
paid for take it away from the IRS if
you're going to give it to Israel but
now he's negotiating with himself he's
now saying I'm going to pass Israel Aid
without any pay for and I'm not for that
it's like why do that you've passed it
tell the senate they need to step up and
do something and tell the senate why
won't you pass it and pay for it what do
you think the reason is because I think
a lot of people are wondering the
Democrats hate to pay for things but
they're the Republicans are buckling and
so Johnson is hearing all these voices
and he's buckling and actually Israel
hasn't even been clamoring for another
14 billion they got 3 and A2 billion
last year they got a lot of money from
us every year and the thing is is having
it paid for and having any foreign aid
paid for any new foreign aid paid for by
a reduction in spending at the IRS wow
that's that should be a win right right
and a lot of this IRS money the
Democrats are already uh willing to
trade it for other things and so I think
it's a big mistake for the speaker I'm
very disappointed that he's now going to
pass a new bill UNP unpaid for Aid to
Israel instead of saying stick to your
guns right but Biden saying if they do a
clean bill on that he's going to veto it
which is good let's let's bizarre for a
Democrat I I I would love to see the day
when President Biden vetos Aid to Israel
right no way let's talk about this book
for a second I had you on and we
discussed it I think we're in the I
think unfortunately we're in the a bit
of a minority at the moment of people
who still wanted a reckoning for some of
the people that did this to this country
uh do you think there's going to be any
Reckoning do you think fouchi will maybe
maybe have his uh what does he get 400
Grand a year still for the rest of his
life could we get some of that back the
the main thing to me is a reckoning but
the Reckoning is and this is the purpose
of the book deception is to make sure
everybody understands all of the facts
and all of the evidence that uh lead us
to believe it came from the lab and the
reason is this could happen again so
sure I'd love for fouy to go to jail
he's committed a felony he lied to
Congress that is a felony and if you
were in the Trump Administration or a
political appointee of trump they'd put
him in because they'll do it and the law
swings One Way apparently but the thing
is is the book's point is also not just
for uh retribution against those who
broke the law but it's to set the
predicate for a reform this this
research still goes on not just in Wuhan
China it goes on in the United States
and we've had a a great amount of
difficulty getting information in fact
in my office the other day I met with
someone we we mentioned in the book a uh
think he was a major at the time he's a
lieutenant colonel in the Marines he
revealed the study from DARPA that
wasn't funded but that shows that the
Chinese and American scientists were
wanting to create a virus that looks
just like covid-19 in 2018 and not one
of these scientists steep forward to say
oh my goodness it looks like they did
what what what they were trying to do
nobody stepped forward and said wow this
looks like it probably came from the lab
because this is what they already told
us they wanted to do not one of the
American scientists steep forward and
the book goes through all of these
details the cover up and really there
wasn't organized covering up including
and led by Anthony fouchy Francis
Collins and a dozen other scientists and
they really did things that scientists
don't normally do they started pointing
fingers and saying you're a conspiracy
theorist if you believe this came from
the lab and it turns out was literally
sending emails to friends saying masks
don't work while he was telling us to
mask virtually everything he said in
private was fairly accurate and true and
virtually everything he said in public
was a lie are you shocked as are you
shocked as a physician that the level of
nonsense that you have have to deal with
when you're when you're interrogating
these guys it's amazing to me so before
this became politicized you know they
used to talk about pandemics they've
been talking about the potential
pandemic for 20 30 years or more and
when they would they would examine
things to do they never once talked
about mask because they all knew mask
didn't work never once did they think
that a respiratory or aerosolized virus
that you catch through the respiratory
system that masks would work and then
all a sudden they're doing it and then
they're finally saying well maybe they
don't work but they're kind of a
Talisman and they're kind of you're
you're just not a polite person if
you're not willing to wear a mask show
that you care about people and it's like
well why don't I care more about if I
wear ear muffs and goggles would that
really convince them I care even more
about the virus even though they make no
sense um and then finally when the
evidence is out there and accumulated
cockran analysis 78 randomized control
studies Mass don't work all the state
comparisons California to Florida all of
that school comparisons they don't work
they had no evidence of any kind of uh
decrease in the spread of this and yet
the other side's like oh well no no all
right I got one more for you because I
know you're tight on time which is are
you hopeful at least after everything we
have learned about covid after the last
few years of just everyone now seeing
the Border nonsense just so much
craziness from our government that if
the next pandemic or when the next
pandemic comes that more people will
have woken up to the ideas of Liberty
and freedom and won't just lock
themselves down and and abide more
people have woken up and there's a
question of which way we go will people
resist enough that we gain our freedoms
and government won't go further or will
the government take the advice of people
like Anthony fouchy Who Loved what China
did and said if we could only be China
in other words fog people in the streets
have people in white suits weld them and
seal them into their hermetically seal
them into their apartment that's the
question is which way we'll go I will
say that even though the government went
the wrong way on almost all of this the
lockdowns and the coercion the one thing
that was encouraging is the internet and
people people on Rumble who resisted the
movement became big enough that we
actually for the first time voted
against a mandate on vaccines in
Congress we ended the vaccine mandate
for the military and every day I meet
people who were resisting some of them
were 16 years into the military some
were 19 years in and because of their
beliefs and wanting their own medical
Choice were willing to give up their
entire career not to take the vaccine
and have one at least F35 pilot that uh
uh by voting on this and getting it
changed he was able to save his career
because he was willing to leave not be
vaccinated and either way you live in
Kentucky and I live in Florida so we'll
be okay Senator thank you if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop screaming check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell